thanks to kiwico for supporting this
episode of journey to the micro cosmos
click the link in the description to
learn more and for a special offer
there have been a lot of significant
moments
in evolutionary history there's the
emergence of unicellular life
the endosymbiotic origin of chloroplasts
and mitochondria
the transition from life and water to
life on land
and all the mass extinctions along the
way
[Music]
more than 600 million years ago one
particular group of single-celled
eukaryotes
faced their own very important fork in
the road
today we call that group and its
descendants
the coenozo but at that point in time
there were just some single cells
staring down
to futures in one future
they would continue life as single cells
in the other
they would become something entirely
different something
that we have to be extremely grateful
for because down
that other fork came the metazoans more
commonly known as
animals so us
for the conozoa that went down that
route cells would divide and develop
and bind together creating biological
links
and relationships that we see as a whole
animal
instead of just individual cellular
selves
and while we could spend this episode
marveling at the complexity of animal
life
you might also be wondering what about
that first group of eukaryotes
the ones who didn't follow the animal
path
what happened to them what do they even
look like
well they look kind of like this
no not the big gold things those are
sanura
and not the big clear thing in the
middle either that's an empty frustual
of a diatom no
we're talking about that small balloon
looking thing
hanging out on top of the diatom so
what is that it is a coenophagelet but
you
can call it a sibling a very very
very distant sibling of sorts but a very
important one found in both marine and
fresh water we've only identified around
150 extant species of coanoflagellates
but this single-celled flagellate is the
closest ancestor
that we know of two animals
the word koeno translates to funnel in
ancient greek
a reference to the collar that wraps
around one end of the coenophalangelete
that collar is made up of microvilli a
series of thin
projections but under most microscopes
it's difficult to make out the
individual microvilli and instead they
blend together into one
big cone encased in that collar
is the organism's single flagella which
it uses to create
currents in the water to shake up and
draw in their favorite food
bacteria some conor flagellates are
non-modal meaning they spend most of
their life not moving around
instead they just stick themselves to a
nice sturdy surface and grab whatever
food passes by
there are also modal coenophagulates
which move around with their flagella
but in a
kind of weird way you see other
flagellates like this euglena
use the twisting rotor movement of their
flagella to pull them around the micro
cosmos
but conoflagelets use their flagellum to
push themselves through the water and
all these things make cohen flagellates
interesting to watch
but if you're looking at them and
wondering how they could possibly be
the closest relatives to animals
we don't blame you so what made
biologists look at them
and see any kind of kinship to animals
why not some other protist to see the
resemblance
you have to go to something a bit more
fundamental when it comes to animals
the sponge yes the sponges you find in
the ocean
and also occasionally in fresh water are
animals
very primitive ones and in 1867 when
naturalist
henry james clark published an article
documenting the conoflagellates
he did more than just describe their
appearance
he compared them to the flagellated
cells that live
inside the chamber of sponges a
resemblance that would be further
emphasized
when those sponge cells were named
coanocytes
[Music]
james clark wrote of their similarities
in a paper titled
conclusive proof of the animality of the
ciliate sponges
and of their affinities with the
infusoria flagellata
we have to say that conclusive proofs is
a bold statement coming from a biologist
especially given the number of occasions
during our journey through the
microcosmos where we have seen
morphological similarities between
organisms
suggesting a close kinship that genetic
research
eventually undermines but on the other
hand
maybe we have a bit of a bias towards
those kinds of stories because a shift
in understanding is part of what makes a
story
compelling but what makes james clark's
observation
fascinating is that a century later his
observations
and conclusions would be supported by
electron microscopy
which deepened our understanding of the
structures shared by conoflagellates
and coenocytes and those observations
would later be validated by
molecular phylogeny which not only
established the genetic resemblance but
named coenoflagellates as the nearest
relative
to animals knowing this
fact about coenoflagellates does more
than just
illuminate our evolutionary lineage
it helps shed light on what hundreds of
millions of years of evolution
might have looked like from the
differences and similarities that exist
between coheno flagellates and sponges
we can start to make predictions
about our last common ancestor that
unknown
organism that came before the fork
in the evolutionary road what we have in
common
suggests traits that may have existed in
that ancestor
like the flagellum and collar that we
see in both
the coenophagulates and the sponge
coanicite
and the similarities go beyond the
morphological
while investigating the coenoflagelet
genome scientists
found a number of genes encoding
proteins
that help cells stick to each other
these particular proteins were thought
to be
an animal thing acting like glue that
keeps our cells bound together
so it's not completely clear why cohen
flagellates
have this molecule but the fact that
they do
along with the observation that some
species group together into colonies
suggests that whatever our mysterious
shared ancestor
was it was likely capable of some basic
form of multicellularity metazoans
just ran with it
and of course the work continues with
scientists
looking to coanoflagelets for whatever
kinship can give us insight
into our past this is why we look to
family and genealogy isn't it
we go to our past to our ancestry to
understand
more about ourselves we seek answers in
our family resemblances
and find questions and the differences
and
so while coeonoflagellates may seem like
an
unlikely sibling they are also it seems
a generous one
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen
world that surrounds us and thank you
again to kiwiko who is supporting this
episode
kiwico creates very cool
hands-on projects for kids that make
learning fun
with the kiwico subscription each month
the kid in your life will receive
a fun engaging new project they have
eight subscription lines each catering
to different age groups and
topics and each box is designed by
experts
and tested by kids in their koala crate
intended for ages 2 to 4 which is the
one that
i currently get with me and my son your
little one can learn how
rainbows are formed while they design
and dye their own rainbow tote bag
along with other educational and
creative projects
it's great it's just a nice thing to
arrive in the mail and a thing for me to
do with my son
so if you want to give a gift that keeps
the fun and learning going all year long
head on over to kiwico.com
journey50 and use the code journey50 or
just click the link in the description
for 50 off your first month of
any crate thank you as always
to our patrons their names are on the
screen right now and they are amazing
they are the reason that we can make
this show it is not a normal show and so
we do need support from folks like you
so
if you like what we do here these are
the folks to thank and if you want to
learn more about how to become one of
them
you can go to patreon.com journey to
micro
if you want to see more from our master
of microscopes james weiss check out jam
and germs on instagram
it is an absolute joy to follow and if
you want to see more from us
there's probably a subscribe button
somewhere nearby
[Music]
you